the spring semester at the University of
Idaho starts today that's nearly two
months after four students were murdered
in their house near the campus 28 year
old Brian coburger was arrested late
last month and charged with the killings
Lilia Luciano reports on the reaction
from the campus in Moscow Idaho
it was a shock for many of our our
students that something like this would
happen here the spring semester is
underway at the University of Idaho dean
of students Blaine eichel said the goal
of the administration is to return a
sense of normalcy for students our
students want to be in community they
want to be here for many students it'll
be the first time back on campus since
the murders of Kaylee Gonzalez Madison
Mogan zaneker nodal and Ethan Chapin
eichel says safety is a top priority
we've increased the relationship with
the Lata County Sheriff's Office so
they're going to have a presence on
campus we've also hired additional
campus security officers and we're still
in very close partnership with the
Moscow Police Department Stu students
were on winter break when Brian coburger
was arrested on December 30th for the
murders which happened at the women's
off-campus home in the early morning
hours of November 13th we sat down with
five freshmen at the University some of
them expressed praise for law
enforcement and a sense of relief that a
suspect was in custody including 18 year
olds Aiden hedinger and Cole pawlik what
they did and what in relatively a short
amount of time inclined it was kind of a
relief just knowing that they have
someone but others like Madeline Pollock
also a teen are still on edge
I'm very paranoid so I kept a lot of my
safety still up 18 year old twins Owen
and Olivia West say the crime
transformed campus life I had never like
originally walked with like a knife for
like my keys between my fingers before
fearing for their safety the twins did
not return to campus after Thanksgiving
break and are still grappling with one
question why them some of them are just
starting like their new life like why
did you take that from them
as much as Campus Life is starting to
get back to normal here at the
University this case is only now getting
started Brian coburger the suspect is
expected back in court tomorrow morning
and if he is convicted he faces the
death penalty and Nate I'm already
hearing a lot of support for that here
in town
Lilia thank you